I want to get some new CDs to listen to at home.
Do you have any recommendations?
Sure, what kind of music are you looking for?
I'd like to get a variety of stuff.
Well, as far as rock goes,...
...the "Nighthawks" have a great new album that just came out.
Really? Yeah, I think I've heard of them.
That might be good.
Also, for the easy listening there is a collection of ...
...great chill-out songs on a CD called "House Arrest".
Do you have a copy of that CD?
Yes, I do.
I'd be happy to let you borrow it if you like.
Okay, thank you. That'd be great.
Why don't you come over to my place this weekend and listen to some of my CDs?
Maybe it will help you decide what you want to buy.
That sounds like a great idea!